[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous
[Musique]
un esprit fun and my guitar n'y a qu'un
creux vos fans maintenant on y standing
ils compliquent l'hyper live from the
people
nous sommes bénis ce que
[Musique]
détail piquant comme
aux états unis comme un coeur
ouais comme
e
quand
oh
non
coc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
bon
[Musique]
oh
à
[Musique]
oh
un livre de l'homme avos frites de
renève kate mais pas là où on se crée
avec de celui fourie à coude est belle
de quel faux sang - herbes hautes mises
à mort depuis
m
à découvrir
picot
corps
on a mis comme un gant
[Musique]
côté là
au détail piquant encore
e
nous
[Musique]
et auquel est tout prêt du fesf ils ont
tous affirmé joe naïve elle n'est pas
tout à fait un
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans une zone boisée starring com
[Musique]
parti depuis qu il est comme un corps
picot
rudd et la paix comme des droits
[Musique]
au départ déconne pas grave
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et ben moi j'ai grandi en israël un pays
avec beaucoup de problèmes très
complexes et assez isolé et quand je
suis toute petite je découvre la musique
alors au début je tombe amoureuse de
mozart ensuite je découvre joni mitchell
et je découvre si nina simone
bjork les vitesses chopin et caetera et
et tous ces gens là que je connais pas
et pain il me raconte tout sur eux ils
se montrent d'une manière est loin
d'être parfaite
et puis vient de plein de cultures de
pays de religion différente
voilà toutes ses diversités et pourtant
je suis dans ma petite chambre d'enfant
et je me semble complètement lié à eux
est donc très vite je me retrouve à
composer mes propres chansons
j'ai peut-être neuf ans et je vis des
sensations que j'arrive pas à comprendre
mais qui sont très fortes
je suis traversé par une sorte
d'évidence qui sort de moi et c'est
comme si mon inconscient se met à me
dire des choses et quand j'écoute après
ce qui est sorti et ben j'arrive à
comprendre des choses que je n'arrivais
pas à comprendre sur moi même avant et
est en fait je me rends compte que la
musique m'aide à me connecter vers le
monde extérieur mais aussi vers le monde
vers mon monde intérieur
et donc est donc je me dis quand je
serai grande et ben je vais partir à la
découverte du monde extérieur et de tous
et tous ces autres les autres qu'on m'a
appris à avoir peur d'eux mais en fait
ça ne marchait pas j'avais pas peur de
tous ces autres donc je voulais aller
découvrir qui sont les autres et puis à
la même occasion peut-être un peu qui je
suis moi même aussi donc l' aventure
commence
j'ai 21 ans j'arrive avec mes bagages à
paris et avec ma musique dans les poches
et il se passe des choses bien je
commence à travailler dans le lundi ce
tri de la musique
mais très vite je me retrouve à être
tiraillé par plein d'avis différents sur
ce que je dois faire tout le monde à une
lors de projections de certitudes et je
me retrouvais à essayer de satisfaire
les autres et petit à petit je me perds
et un moment je me sens vraiment trop
malheureuse je me dis voilà ça vaut pas
la peine
ça vaut pas la peine je vais pas tenir
le coup et j'ai décidé d'un jour au bout
de quelques années comme ça d'
abandonner toute l'idée de faire une
carrière dans la musique
donc voilà je me retrouve à 25 ans alors
que j'ai tout quitté pour ça en quelque
sorte
si on retrouve à 25 ans seule à paris
dans l'échec total et une fois passée
une petite étape de panique je me
détends un peu et en fait je me rends
compte que je suis soulagé je suis
soulagé parce que tout d'un coup
ben j'ai plus rien à gagner mais du coup
ça veut dire que ceux plus rien à perdre
donc c'est génial et l envie de faire la
musique l'amour pour la musique reste
intacte donc donc petit à petit je me
mets à faire cette musique qui vient du
plus profond de moi même j'ai décidé de
me permettre de la faire tout simplement
pour rien c'est à dire 10 voilà ça va
peut-être un donné mais il faut que je
la fasse et et voilà j'ai pas trouvé
mieux que des balades en hébreu je me
suis dit comme ça c'est sûr qu'il va
rien se passer
donc je commence à bricoler et puis très
vite tu fais la rencontre avec un être
merveilleux qui s'appelle david donatien
et il me rejoint et ensemble on passe
tous les jours tous nos journées un peu
leur de bureaux quoi de neuf à cinq prix
bien plus à on appelait ça bricoler
parce qu'on n'avait pas de moyens on
n'avait pas donc d'argent ni de matériel
ni l'expérience pour enregistrer
vraiment mais on sort on apprend en
faisant se débrouillent donc parfois
comme on n'a pas de quoi enregistrer par
exemple certains texture ou certaines
rythmique bas on découvre qu'en prenant
des grains de riz et en les frottant sur
un métal et ben ça donne quelque chose
quelqu'un qu'on trouve marrant et puis
ensuite un jour j'ai envie de j'entends
des flûtes dans les arrangements mais
j'ai pas de flûte donc je descends dans
un magasin deuxième 1 je trouve une
vieille frites traversière commerciale
et qui coûte 1 euro je rentre chez moi
et ça me dit après j'enregistre la fuite
et moi je fais échoué au 6e telle était
donc je chantais fenêtres ouvertes ya
les bruits de des voisins qui rend dans
l'enregistrement tout ça c'est
politiquement pas correct mais tant pis
et deux ans s'écoulent comme ça
et au bout de deux ans et demi même ce
truc c'est effet de boule de neige
les choses deviennent hannon et un jour
une chanson qui qui était pour moi une
chanson intime aussi qui parlait de mon
histoire se retrouve à faire le tour du
monde
je vous la fait courte la veille de mes
30 ans je me retrouve à être numéro 1
dans le monde entier
bon ça fait un peu mytho pour ceux qui
savent pas de quoi je parle
ça ressemble un peu à ça c'était 1-1
nous sommes à kernilis streep robin
accueilli partout vivendi games show and
found in the making evry pense aux
mystiques
[Musique]
bref la vie est belle
j'ai retrouvé faire le tour du monde
pendant quelques années je découvre
enfin toutes les cultures que je rêvais
découvrir j'enchaîne les albums jeu
devient maman deux fois et petit à petit
et bain puisque tout va bien j'ai pu
trop le temps pour moment d'extérieur
mon intérieur tout ça voilà donc petit à
petit j'abandonne ce bonhomme ce truc tu
m'abandonnes en quelque sorte et et
petit à petit bas je commence à
m'écarter à m'absenter et a plus trop
mais mais peut-être aussi et ils
nouvelle période commence
où
[Musique]
bon
où
[Musique]
je ne suis pas assez forte pour être
temps pansements pour soigner des
blessures de protéger du vent tout ce
que tu avoues d'avant qui lit pendant
que tu joues au foot
moi je ne vois que des troncs des trous
dans ton coeur
qui tu es loin compte peur tu réclames
le bonheur mais tu fais ferrieu des
trous dans des poses con tu blesses les
plus proches tuerie est tu décroches tu
vois bien que sa clause d trop dans ton
corps ce médoc quittant d'or s'est
jamais toi qui as tôt
puis c'est quand que tu t'en sors des
trous dans tes mains qui me touche 190
qui trouve pas le chemin
tous ces espoirs mme
des trous dans tes pieds tu cours pour
pas tomber
tu dis être ma moitié
moi je veux qu'on soit entier tremble
quand je te sers tu trembles
constellation moi je 2
un amer je n'en peux plus tu nous gages
[Musique]
mais tu casses le soleil
j'ai fini la bouteille toujours les bons
conseils des rêves dont à courber j'ai
pas te sauver ne suis pas tabou et
je n'ai même pas essayé de plus de
regarder se voit qui tue
je vois qui tu ne seras pas mais dieu
que ça fait peur d'avoir pu aimer sa
tête rocky respire c'est ce nous qui
m'inspire qui brisent mon empire qui
m'arrache un soupir
[Musique]
mais quand on va grandir
après tout ce qu'on s'est fait quand on
sera en paix dans un monde imparfait
un jour on va oser
tout simplement s'aimer
6 comme ça comme
[Musique]
voilà donc en fait je vais toutes ces
années je me décale un tout petit peu de
moi même et il ya trois ans à peu près à
la mort de mon père et à la proche de
mecs 40 ans je sens le besoin de
ralentir de faire un certain point bon
peut-être une belle crise de la
quarantaine aussi et je sens le besoin
de faire d'aller d'aller là où j'ai peur
de faire seul un projet qui me tient
vraiment à coeur et que j'appelle les
nights songs et celui là a été difficile
j'ai failli beaucoup beaucoup perdent
pour pouvoir le faire naître et
peut-être en quelque sorte pour pouvoir
me refaire naître aussi
et en plus il a vu il avait jours lors
du confinement et il n'a pas du tout
vécu les feux d'artifice d autres
projets et en fait je me suis rendu
compte d'une chose importante vraiment
importante
c'est qu'en fait il y a rien qui
remplace le sentiment ce sentiment
merveilleux d'avoir s'être permis
d'avoir accompli quelque chose est en
fait j'ai accepté de parler aujourd'hui
malgré que c'est quelque chose qui me
fait très peur a la base je préfère
chanter pour vous dire une chose
importante s'il te plaît permettez vous
vous êtes légitime permettez vous de
vous écouter de vous aimer tels que vous
êtes est en fête
au fond on est lié on est vraiment lié
et beaucoup moins isolés que ce qu'on
croit donc voilà je vous aime
aimez vous aussi merci
ou vous
[Musique]
oh
la pologne
[Musique]
c'est le bail
my phone
[Musique]
tu es owen
cattenom pour
fait que par les eaux
na
nous pas au détail à evreux bafing
fraudeurs comme une folle en reste
forest
mais faut il est un
[Musique]
2 au raf
m
oh
je sais
[Musique]
à
je lai
ghosn
des mots forts
tu es fou
t'at il me faut
[Musique]
foulard et vtt
trop fort
[Musique]
en vain on est vraiment
enfin bref
go
[Musique]
l'eau
oh
[Musique]
encore merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]